[Musica]
i giovani la tecnologia la generazione z
i nati dal 97 al
2012 Eccoli Eccoli
i miei ragazzi della generazione Z sono
i miei studenti di un corso che
impartiscono di Bologna alla triennale
hanno 20 21 22 anni generazione Z quello
che scatta il selfie non è generazione Z
sono io Generazione X La generazione dei
genitori degli Z quelli che Agnese ci ha
detto stanno bruciando il mondo e temo
che abbia ragione
vorrei conoscervi Un pochettino quanti Z
e quanti X ci sono in questa sala
Facciamo così gli Z Al mio tre urlano Z1
2 3
bene quanti X al mio 3 x 1 2 3
grande benissimo Benvenuti a tutti anche
ai boomers ai millennial
devo parlarvi di tecnologia mi hanno
chiesto di parlarvi di tecnologia e
generazione Z del rapporto tra
tecnologia generazione Z La domanda che
mi hanno posto gli organizzatori è
la tecnologia che in futuro avrà un
maggior impatto sulla generazione Z dal
punto di vista sociale e professionale e
di che tipo di impatto stiamo parlando e
allora io la domanda l'ho fatta ai miei
ragazzi e quei 30 ragazzi che avete
visto nella prima foto
hanno risposto con entusiasmo che un
approfondimento delle belle risposte ma
prima di dirvi che cosa mi hanno
risposto Fatemi Permettetemi di fare un
flashback veniamo alla mia generazione
agli X Cioè se a 20 anni a noi degli X
avessero chiesto
che cosa ti aspetti dal futuro Qual è la
tua percezione del futuro quale
tecnologia avrà Maggiore impatto Beh
a vent'anni a me i miei genitori hanno
regalato il mio primo personal computer
io vivevo Allora in un paese di 5.000
anime era il primo personal computer che
c'era in paese ce l'avevo solo io Ero
eccitatissimo potrò fare tantissime cose
e allora l'ho acceso e il cursore ha
cominciato a blinkare bello ho
cominciato a spingere tutti i tasti e il
cursore blinkava
l'ho spento l'ho riacceso il cursore
blincava ho capito che avevo bisogno di
un aiuto e allora un po' di anni fa ho
preso la corriera un'ora di strada e
sono andato a Bologna nel negozio dove i
miei genitori avevano comprato il
personal computer e ho detto il cursore
blinka cosa ci faccio e il tecnico mi ha
chiesto Ma hai messo il floppy col dos
il cosa col cosa
Ecco in quel momento ho capito che
questa tecnologia nuova
straordinariamente eccitante dovevo
guadagnarmela dovevo lavorare duro e
allora ho scoperto un mondo Ho scoperto
il mondo della programmazione
Insomma è cominciato il mio viaggio
verso la tecnologia del futuro
attraverso la scoperta di come dovevo
guadagnare
e quindi la domanda Tornando ai miei
ragazzi è e i miei ragazzi che cosa
devono scoprire che tipo di viaggio
devono affrontare per poter usare con
l'entusiasmo che ci ho messo io
nell'usare il mio primo personal
computer
la tecnologia del futuro
Beh questa domanda la domanda che ho
posto prima oltre
ad averla posta ai miei ragazzi l'ho
proposta a un chatbot credo che molti di
voi lo conoscono da ottobre novembre è
una tecnologia disponibile in rete
gratuitamente un chatbot è una
piattaforma digitale basata su
intelligenza artificiale che risponde a
una domanda tecnicamente un prompt
in maniera
naturale usando un linguaggio naturale
tanto che è difficile riconoscere se la
risposta sia proveniente da un umano o
da una macchina bene Io ho posto la
stessa identica domanda al chatbot
e sapete cosa
mi ha dato esattamente la stessa
risposta dei miei ragazzi
internet delle cose intelligenza
artificiale social network e il
metaverso Queste sono le tecnologie che
avranno impatto nel futuro
o da prima mi sono concentrato sul fatto
che la risposta fosse la stessa dei miei
30 ragazze del chatbot ho cominciato a
porre i problemi del tipo ma
effettivamente la tecnologia si sta
sostituendo alle persone poi però
approfondendo rileggendo le risposte dei
miei ragazzi mi sono reso conto di
qualcosa mi sono reso conto che il
chatbot nella sua rigidità non mi aveva
però trasmesso un'emozione cosa che
invece le risposte dei ragazzi hanno
fatto anche se il contenuto era lo
stesso
le risposte dei miei ragazzi non tutte
ma una parte mi hanno trasmesso un senso
di ansia Sì perché molti di loro hanno
detto Sì sì social network però
quello che mi hanno fatto percepire che
in qualche modo temano di essere
sopraffatti da queste tecnologie e dalle
loro evoluzioni future tendono temono
che in qualche modo inibiscano qualche
loro altra capacità alcuni mi hanno
detto questo menu infinito di questi
social network è come una droga non
riesce a fermarti e quando finalmente ti
fermi dici Ma se io stavo un'ora a bere
una birra con gli amici al bar non era
meglio Eppure il giorno dopo di nuovo
quindi
lo sentono anche avvertono questa
tecnologia un po' come una minaccia alla
fine non c'è un entusiasmo straordinario
Guardate l'ipso su una nota agenzia di
sondaggi ha misurato con un sondaggio a
tardo 2022 che effettivamente rispetto
al metaverso per esempio gli Hicks La
mia generazione sono molto più
entusiasti di utilizzatori degli Z
ma D'altro canto È naturale gli Z sono
digitali nativi Cioè Cosa vuol dire vuol
dire che sono nati con lo Smart for in
tasca con la tecnologia in tasca Ce
l'hanno sulla punta delle dita e come
tutte le cose di cui si vive nella
quotidianità Ma sì li usano li useranno
ma non è quella cosa che Trascina il
loro entusiasmo che scalda i loro cuori
E allora allora ci dobbiamo chiedere che
cosa è che invece scalderà i loro cuori
al punto da essere qualcosa di cui si
può parlare in termini di impatto sulla
generazione Z
Che cos'è che canalizzerà la loro
energia
Ecco c'è stata una risposta in
particolare dei miei ragazzi che mi ha
colpito un ragazzo ha detto prof Io non
lo so non le so rispondere Quale sarà la
tecnologia che avrà un maggiore impatto
su di noi in futuro però le posso dire
una cosa sarà quella che vorrò io
Ecco questa risposta mi è piaciuta molto
mi ha fatto ragionare molto sulla
domanda che avevo posto ai ragazzi la
domanda mi ricordo era quale tecnologia
avrà un impatto su di voi in futuro
sugli Z Forse non era la domanda giusta
forse Guardate la freccia
forse era il viceversa forse quello che
dovevo chiedergli era Ragazzi ma che
impatto volete voi zvere sull'evoluzione
delle tecnologie
Sì perché io credo io credo che questi
ragazzi e Agnese la prima speaker ce
l'ha rappresentato perfettamente
vogliano agire
questi ragazzi vogliono essere attori
non spettatori del futuro vogliono
cambiare il mondo vogliono crearlo e
quindi non vogliono basarsi su ciò che
noi X gli abbiamo costruito e che
useranno Ma vogliono inventare qualche
cosa di nuovo Ecco allora il tema
probabilmente diventa quello di provare
a cercare di immaginare quello che loro
oggi non sanno immaginare e che solo un
esperto di tecnologie può immaginare
cerchiamo quindi di chiederci cosa c'è
dietro l'orizzonte quello che i miei
ragazzi ancora non sanno immaginare
perché non se ne parla ma un esperto può
invece
poi invece immaginare Ecco io credo
Credo che dopo questi anni anche anni
problematici anni in cui appunto Noi
stiamo bruciando il loro mondo Noi x Io
credo che gli Z
gli Z vorranno una tecnologia calda
vorranno una tecnologia che permetta
loro pensate agli anni della pandemia
che abbiamo alle spalle di mettere in
relazione le persone di trasferire di di
facilitare il trasferimento di
sentimenti di emozioni
emozioni
Cosa sono le emozioni da un punto di
vista fisico Guardate sono ingegnere
piedi a terra Che cosa sono le emozioni
ora parliamo di onde cerebrali il nostro
cervello naturalmente è noto in ambito
di neuroscienze da molti anni emettono
il nostro cervello emette onde
elettromagnetiche onde elettromagnetiche
che oscillano tra gli Zero e i 60-70
Hertz Cosa vuol dire 70 Hz vuol dire che
sono onde che oscillano 70 volte al
secondo oppure 10 20 30 40 Hz queste
onde che emette ogni cervello
Naturalmente in ogni momento della
giornata a seconda delle proprie
attività a frequenze diverse tra 0 e 70
Hz queste onde possono essere ricevute
sentite percepite da un altro cervello a
qualche metro di distanza
c'è tanta letteratura scientifica
riguardo Soprattutto negli ultimi due
anni
Ecco è stato dimostrato che se per
esempio due persone lavorano
separatamente su due Task distinti una
vicino all'altra ciascuna stai mettendo
onde cerebrali Ma le onde cerebrali
oscillano del tutto indipendentemente è
stato invece dimostrato misurato che se
quelle due persone cominciano a lavorare
insieme hanno un tasto collaborativo le
loro onde
si sincronizzano
cominciano a oscillare insieme ed è
stato dimostrato che se per giunta nasce
un sentimento di empatia tra le persone
che lavorano insieme o anche qualcosa di
più se vivono un'emozione comune allo
oscillazione crea un unisono è
perfettamente sincronizzata addirittura
addirittura
un articolo di un paio d'anni fa ha
dimostrato che se un musicista è sul
palco e suona
e in sala c'è un apprezzamento per la
sua performance bene le onde cerebrali
del musicista e delle persone nelle sale
si sintonizzano e creano un unico
unisono nella nella stanza
Allora io vorrei proporvi adesso un
esperimento Spero mi seguiate vi chiedo
di chiudere gli occhi per favore
chiudete tutti gli occhi
e poi se lo volete solo se vi va se non
vi crea imbarazzo toccate la mano di chi
vi sta vicino
occhi chiusi
[Musica]
stiamo vivendo un'emozione insieme
le sentite io le sento le onde cerebrali
qua dentro
all'unisono
grazie potete riaprire gli occhi le
avete sentite Io le ho sentite
oscillavano insieme su giù su giù
abbiamo vissuto un'emozione insieme ora
torniamo alla tecnologia
se siete vicini a mezzo metro di
distanza uno dall'altro Forse avete
sentito questa emozione avete sentito
questa sintonia questioni sono ma è
facile siete vicini Ma se invece Siete
lontani Siete lontani da una persona
cara da vostro figlio dal vostro
genitore siete dall'altra parte del
mondo E vorreste vivere quelle emozioni
insieme Beh allora ci vuole la
tecnologia ad aiutarvi la tecnologia di
comunicazione che vi mette in relazione
con quella persona a distanza oggi nel
2023 abbiamo il 5G e 5G una
straordinaria tecnologia di
comunicazione che può fare tante cose
mette in connessione macchine automobili
persone ma venendo alla
comunicazione tra persone e cinque così
Che cosa fa ci permette di di scambiare
informazioni riguardo a due sensi tra i
molti di quei dotato l'uomo no l'udito e
la vista e gli altri gli altri mancano
Ecco allora provando a guardare oltre
l'orizzonte come esperto di
telecomunicazioni vi dico che il 6G che
arriverà nel 2030 il 6G permetterà di
fare più di questo oltre all'udito e la
vista permetterà di trasmettere anche
in qualche modo di coinvolgere altri
sensi come l'olfatto e il tatto Come
sarà possibile perché i dispositivi
Saranno talmente miniaturizzati che
potranno essere ovunque sul nostro corpo
dotati di sensori per misurare tutte
tutte le grandezze fisiche del nostro
corpo saranno su collane e braccialetti
bracciali
auricolari eccetera eccetera e quindi ci
permetteranno di trasmettere oltre udito
visto anche il fatto è tratto
e io non so se lo farà il 6G non ve lo
prometto ma sicuramente lo farà il 7g
che arriverà alla fine degli anni 30
quelli in cui il Z Saranno nel pieno
della loro vita sociale professionale
bene quello che Si aggiungerà in seguito
sarà la possibilità di trasmettere anche
le onde cerebrali così che sarà
possibile effettivamente a distanza
migliaia di chilometri di distanza
vivere la stessa emozione come l'abbiamo
vissuta qua dentro per qualche secondo
grazie a Sebastian che ci ha suonato
Beethoven Ecco questa è una tecnologia
calda forse un po' oltre l'orizzonte che
i ragazzi ancora non sanno riconoscere
non conoscono Ma questa è una tecnologia
calda che mettere in relazione le
persone Io credo che gli Z di questa
tecnologia si innamoreranno Io credo che
questa vorranno e quindi siccome sono
attori e non spettatori questa creeranno
a questa dedicheranno la loro energia e
il loro entusiasmo Buona serata e buona
vita a tutti